[Music]
mr malcolm's list is a romantic comedy
certainly in the 1800s it's quite funny
in a modern and rounded way the whole
concept of dating and courtship and the
games that people play it's not really
different from modern days so what did
he say about me
a young society lady julia thistlewake
gets publicly jilted by the biggest
catch of the season mr malcolm she then
discovers malcolm has a list of
requirements she did not match up to
he's very picky and choosy about the
type of woman he wants to marry next
thing you know you'll be checking her
teeth i'll add that to the list
my character's julia's cousin and
malcolm's best friend and finds himself
stuck
in the middle did you see it
no
yes
julia engages on this plan to get her
revenge on mr malcolm using her friend
selena if we present you as a perfect
woman and he discovers he does not meet
the requirements on your list that would
be a perfect sort of poetic justice
it doesn't go exactly as you plan
from the first time malcolm and selena
meet each other there's sparks just
flying already you contend you hope for
something worthy i do indeed
it's a female driven story it's directed
produced and written all by women in
2018 we were able to create this proof
of concept to really give us a launch
pad for the feature some of our original
cast from this feature were in the short
film emma holly jones our director wants
to create a mr darcy and lizzie bennett
for any child of color emma's take on
regency england has a very contemporary
edge i grew up watching jane
austen-based movies and tv shows and so
now with mr malcolm's list i was invited
to the table
you can sort of really feel those flirty
tensions and chemistries building
between the various parties and then
breaking this all up with some brilliant
comedy in the film miss thistle way say
that one twenty times miss this with mrs
i think you have a romantic comedy in
1818 with a plot that's about revenge
and romance so it's gonna be juicy
love cannot be planned so carefully
[Music]
it's the sort of film we all need right
now we need romance we need escape
i hope people truly enjoy the whole
gamut of experiences and feelings from
this movie
[Music]
very happy you're here
good to be here
[Music]
[Music]
you